hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the most central themes in the
grand inquisitor chapter in fedor
dostoevsky is the brothers karamazov
book five
is that of freedom you see this word
popping up
over and over again it doesn't always
mean exactly the same thing it's kind of
a slippery equivocal
term and it is something that
is being discussed in order to
say it's great say it's bad say it's
problematic
and we can also talk about the dynamic
that is being laid out being narrated by
the grand inquisitor
the idea is that freedom is
a problem for human beings and this is
interesting because
typically in the history of philosophy
and so many other things we talk about
freedom as being a great thing
we can't have enough of it it's
wonderful
christ is being depicted here as he is
in so many other places
as having come to free human beings to
give them more
freedom and the grand inquisitor is
saying freedom you know can be a good
thing but it's also
a abyss it's a terrible thing it is
it presents so many problems for human
beings that if we want them to be
happy we need to free humanity
of their freedom and one way that you
can free humanity of course is just
imposing some sort of order upon them
and saying everybody will do
exactly as we say otherwise we'll
kill you we'll torture you we'll do
terrible things to you that's actually a
very ineffective way
of trying to get rid of freedom instead
you have to
you have to work at it you have to
figure out how freedom
operates and what the things that free
human beings
desire are and then how to get them to
give that freedom
up freely and so the grand inquisitor
talks here he says that
the people are more certain than ever
before that they are completely free
at the same time they themselves have
brought us their freedom and obediently
laid it at their feet it is our doing
is it what you wanted this sort of
freedom
and then eliosha because this is a
conversation of course between alyosha
the younger brother and ivan eliot says
i don't understand is he being ironic
and and
ivan says not on the least he lays it to
his and his colleagues credit that they
finally overcome freedom have done so in
order to make people
happy so what's going on here
so this let's talk about what freedom is
first
freedom by its very nature the freedom
that human beings possess
cannot be brought under one rigid
concept
because it escapes that freedom is
always
going to be more free than one would
like it to be
because freedom can also be used to
decide what our very freedom means this
is
sort of a typical existentialist
position on freedom and that's
running through here because dostoevsky
is one of the first existentialists
so freedom is a capacity for ourselves
to choose things to some people would
also define it
as being able to do what it is that we
want
and there's a number of different ways
of understanding freedom but even
more important is the capacity to choose
how we're going to commit ourselves
whether we're going to pursue good
or choose evil it is possible to choose
evil according to somebody like
dostoevsky
a lot of philosophers have said oh
people never choose evil for its own
sake
it's always under the guise of something
else true but you can like
dimly suspect that the thing that you're
choosing is wrong and still choose it
whether it be pleasure
or making money or whatever in certain
circumstances right
rebellion itself could be could be a
good thing could be a bad thing
human beings have this raw capacity that
they're often not
fully aware of and often we can say
never fully
exercise in any one single act
now interestingly the grand inquisitor
says
nothing is more insufferable for humans
and human society than freedom and you
might say well why would that possibly
be the case freedom is great it's what
allows us to choose the right thing
it's what allows us to decide what to
make of ourselves
yes but it's also what allows us to
choose
to impose horrible suffering or even
just annoyance
on other people including innocent
children as talked about
in the chapter just before it's what
allows us to accept god
or to reject god or to get into
interminable arguments about what
exactly god is or
what god said and how to interpret what
god said and
all these sorts of things freedom
by itself is not always
experienced as a wonderful thing when
somebody is an aggressor towards you
or even says words that you find
disconcerting
because they disrupt your uh view of the
world or your health you know closely
held dogmas
that's their use of their freedom they
are also free beings
and you can find yourself as a free
being doing terrible things as well to
others to yourself
freedom is also something that makes us
responsible that says you
bear a weight upon your shoulders you
choose good or evil
you are the chooser choose rightly and
if we choose the wrong thing and we bear
the consequences of it
sometimes we say things like why didn't
somebody stop me
you know well because you're free right
so freedom
is you know a terrible burden for human
beings it's also you know sort of a
crowning achievement and a way that
we're
similar to other rational beings and to
god
but it is very difficult for people to
to bear and the grand inquisitor talks
about
christ's coming not at this point in
time but although it's a danger
right now but um in in the narrative
but about his his original coming this
is the eternal
entering into time this is god taking on
flesh and walking among human beings and
loving them and teaching them and
dying for them ultimately all of this is
supposed to
provide greater freedom and he
criticizes christ saying
you know you could have taken their
freedom from them you could have
actually made them happy
instead you actually like worsened the
problem
of the human condition so the advent of
the what we call the christ event which
is really a whole set of events
that actually sort of opened up a wound
within the world and within human nature
rather than simply healing everything it
made
our difficulties even worse because now
instead of just having an old law that
you're supposed to follow
now you've got to choose between the old
law and and christ
the new law the gospel right
and you also have to choose how you're
going to interpret that and you have to
choose whether you're going to follow it
christ's coming didn't actually make
things easier
and actually you know i think dostoevsky
would say for any christians out there
who say oh i've got everything figured
out because i've got jesus
he would probably say that's actually
not christianity
again an existentialist position on that
so
christ gets criticized for giving humans
more freedom which is not necessarily a
good thing for them
it depends on what they make of that
freedom
he's also criticized for having done the
things that he does
because he's capable of it not taking
account of how
weak and corrupt human beings actually
are that they're likely to make bad use
of that freedom
that he's given that christ is giving
them
there's another discussion that's also
relevant to this
and i think you know the the setting for
this is the
you know 1500s right but dostoyevsky is
writing
towards his own time in this case ivan
is you know speaking
on behalf of this new age that we're in
the age of enlightenment
in which you know there's freedom of
different sorts people are becoming
emancipated
politically economically free reason
that was sort of a a hallmark of the
enlightenment and that it's spread into
society
people get to to think and choose for
themselves and the sciences
and the the grand inquisitor says he's
sort of predicting
what's going to be happening ahead of
time these lead
human beings into a maze
a labyrinth we often think of
well you know the capacity to use your
political or economic or social
freedom and you know the ability to
think by yourself
and you know develop the sciences
reliable ways of understanding
the natural world the human beings all
sorts of other things
as well these are just going to make
everything fall into place
no they actually make us more of an
enigma to ourselves
all the people who are like you know
neuroscience has shown us xyz
you know they would be perfect examples
of this and you
wonder what they think in the dead of
the night
when they realize the foundations of
their sciences are
so shaky and that there's so much
that's being um sort of willed this is
very
similar to a nietzschean conception here
on the part of
ivan talking through the grand
inquisitor
these things we could we could believe
in them as sort of dogmas
but the more that you actually know
about
these matters the more in which you
experience them the shakier things get
and the more
our freedom bedevils us so this is the
grand inquisitor's
complaint and case now what is the
remedy
well the grand inquisitor and his
colleagues they are
an elite class of human beings and they
are going to as human beings
make use of their own freedom to
change the situation for human beings
they can't
radically change human nature they've
got to work with that
they can't eliminate the fact that
christ came and made things more
complicated
although they can try to you know stem
that right now with this
christ showing up again which is what
the grand inquisitor is doing
but they can at least work with the you
know
way in which society is set up to take
that freedom
and do something with it they can free
humanity of freedom and so he goes on
uh only now and this is ivan he says
he's referring of course to the
inquisition has it become possible to
think for the first time about human
happiness
man was made a rebel how can can rebels
be happy
you were warned you had no lack of
warnings and indications but you did not
heed the warnings
you rejected the only way of arranging
for human happiness
but fortunately on your departure you
handed the work over to us he's talking
to christ
christ should have brought human
happiness instead he brought freedom
and then handed it over to the church
and now the church
as this you know organization governing
human beings
they're going to make human beings happy
at last
he says you promised you established
with your word you gave us the right to
bind and
loose and so
how is this actually going to be
understood
well the grand inquisitor and his
colleagues
this this long process of self-selecting
elite human beings have
figured out the fundamental problematics
of
humanity the human condition and they're
going to prioritize happiness which
means that
freedom has to be used to
as much as possible eliminate itself
so what is the the key here get humanity
to
freely lay their freedom at the feet of
the grand inquisitor
the inquisition the church whatever it's
going to be
now here's a good place to pause this
this uh
presentation here this poem on the part
of ivan
doesn't necessarily have to be about the
catholic church it could be about
any form of social organization
in which there's an elite that is saying
we understand the human condition we're
going to fix things for it for you
place your trust in us give us your
freedom
freely give us your freedom and we will
make you happy
so there's a lot wider scope here but
coming back to the sort of explicitly
christian
setting this is all articulated
in accordance with the three temptations
found in the gospel account of christ
fasting in the desert
and then being tempted by the dreaded
intelligent spirit the spirit of
self-destruction
and non-being the devil right
and there are three um temptations
and with each one christ responds
actually by by citing a
a biblical verse so he says
this is ivan he says that
was it possible to say anything more
true than what he proclaimed to you in
his three questions which you rejected
in which the books refer to
as temptations these provide a sort of
framework for understanding
the human condition so
here's here's another thing he says it's
quite interesting
if it were possible to imagine these
three questions of the dread spirit had
been lost from the books without a trace
and it was necessary they'd be restored
thought up and invented anew
to be put back into the books and to
that end all the wise men on earth
were brought together and given this
task to think up to invent three
questions
such as would not only correspond to the
scale of the event the devil and christ
but moreover would express in three
words in three human phrases only
the entire future history of the world
and mankind goes on and he says
the questions alone simply by the
miracle of their appearance we can see
we're dealing with a mind not human and
transient but eternal
and absolute in these three questions
all of subsequent human history is
as if brought together in a single whole
and foretold so
you know this is quite an interesting
speculation here
about uh you know the nature of these
these questions essentially being
eternal
and the three temptations provide a
framework
for harnessing human freedom
the first one is bread you know why
don't you
the hungry person turn these stones
into bread and thereby feed yourself and
then by extension
why don't you christ turn you know
things into bread and provide
for human needs well we'll do that for
you
because what we're doing there is
providing security we're providing
freedom from want and if you could just
provide
these then human beings
will lay their freedom down at your feet
they will give up their freedom in order
to have
material prosperity or even just
survival and security
so that's that's one important source
of the freedom being used by the people
to give up their freedom the second
miracles mystery and authority the grand
inquisitor
says human beings don't just have to
live
they have to have something to live for
they need something to believe in
by not giving enough miracles
not having enough mystery and authority
you make things shaky you let people
choose for themselves there were times
in the
in the biblical accounts where christ
would be asked to do a miracle and he'd
say nah you know
faith that's important better to believe
without seeing these
miracles or as they're called in the
book of the gospel john
signs better to believe
without this stuff that's your choice
but a lot of people are like no
no no i gotta have a sign and then the
sign won't be enough they're like i need
somebody to interpret that sign for me
an authority
i need to i need to be secure there's a
kind of security
that's not just one of material things
but of spiritual things
finally power and authority the
temptation
is see all these kings kingdoms of the
earth just you know
you want them i'll give them to you and
christ says nah
let those alone so somebody will come
along
when you turn down power you can be
guaranteed that you're not turning it
down
you know for yourself and then the power
goes away
somebody else will come along and take
it and why is it important that that
happen
because there is within humanity this
universal
desire for what the grand inquisitor
calls a universal and gen
general union a concord a
harmony of people an end to conflict
these three things certainty
security harmony these are very
powerful objects of desire for
human beings not least because by the
way that we use our freedom
we often don't have these so the grand
inquisitor
is getting the human beings the grand
inquisitor and all of his colleagues
to abandon their freedom to lay their
freedom
down at the feet of this power elite
this intellectual elite this elite that
provides them with security
in order for them to live a happy
existence so we have freedom versus
happiness which are you going to choose
and the masses choose because the
problem has been set up in such a way
the masses choose happiness and to give
up their freedom
you